before you give me the answers what was
your strategy what way did you approach
this question any takers
yeah okay so you can see like what this
salt that you would go over this number
last week solve is search for values for
your protein rules that will satisfy
these equations now these are not just
any equations these are not some bonus
somes hideous equations so what we mean
is I want the pair of values for x and y
that will simultaneously work for this
and for this which is why if you're
testing it's important that you test the
moment equations that's sort of
significant right so I'm looking for
values for X Y you've got two variables
x and y which means you need to
equations so you can remove one of them
now we have a fancy word that starts
with E rather using the word remove we
call it elimination right so in either
of these cases right you could eliminate
a variable I'm actually gonna have a
look at this one it's bit easier to the
illustrate for what's the quickest way
you could have eliminated variable in
question to say just so you can add
these two and to do this properly
you really should name these and then
you would simply write it like this
right and all that means is and
everything on the left-hand side for
each then had everything on the ring
inside for each and you'll get a new
equation which combines both of them I
mean in this case why do we choose to
add them why not say subtract we're just
adding achievement yeah very good so you
can see this guy here and this guy here
will be eliminated because they're
exactly opposite to each other okay in
the first one what would you do if you
wanted to achieve something similar
so if I call this equation 2 this is
equation 1 I could say equation 2 times
2 that would then become ax plus 2y
equals 48 and you could proceed in a
similar way now that's all by
elimination we have another method of us
leave to do this did anyone approach it
differently yes your honor
okay we can also solve by substitution
so probably I mean either of these you
could if we were doing this one by
substitution this would not be your
first step there be something else you
would do to take a different path
through the question what else yeah okay
so you can see I've got a coefficient of
one on this term already so if I've
already got this coefficient of one
what's the use of that well what I then
do from there if I've got a coefficient
before yeah okay so if I rearrange just
a little bit
rather than multiply everything by two I
will rearrange and by the way just like
if you were writing an essay and every
essay that you have with a paragraph has
like a top except it just like this is
what it's about these are kind of like
your topic sentences for all of your
working right you should have maybe two
or three of these sort of spaced down
throughout your working so that you say
okay now I'm doing this now you didn't
like you that you change you say okay
well now I'm going in a different
direction and then you have your work I
suggested if I change the subject I
guess I would have something like this
what would I do with that
yeah technically yeah you would pop it
back in here now I want to just point
out some of you this worth whether you
don't wait to the Navy equations okay at
this point here after rearranging this
equation I have a new equation so I
would usually name this something else
now a very common name is to call it
equation 3
it's the third equation I'm going to
suggest that's a bad idea or at least
there's a better idea I'm going to call
it - a the reason why is because it came
from Equation 2 so those two are linked
and it helps me remember okay don't put
this guy back into equation 2 back where
he came from
does anyone know what happened if you
put it back into the equation came from
hmm it doesn't take long
let's just try it and see what happens
I'm gonna put this back into here okay
so let's see 4 X plus now instead of
writing Y I'm gonna write already 4
minus 4 x equals 24 and as soon as you
finish writing that you're like oh right
you have ended up with something true it
is true that 4 X plus 24 minus 4 X is
equal to 24 it's true it just happens to
be useless to you right so it doesn't
get you any further because you've put
something back into where it came from
so that's why as I suggested we should
put it back into equation 1 and then you
can simplify a bit are you happy with
that what our solution is just so he can
get some agreement once a guy facts 7
and values Y negative
right have we got a date set for
question 2 as well x equals 5 and y
equals no okay no yes no something else
who disagrees discuss my awesome yeah
negative one and okay now let's just
pause on this moment for a second
because there are two things worth
noting here one of the great things
about solving simultaneous equations
solving questions in general actually
there are many areas of that's where you
never have to be in doubt without an
answer key or anything you can find out
whether your solution is correct or not
how would you do it in this case you
would put it back into the original
equations okay so I can substitute each
of these values for x and y back in and
they should work for both and they've
got away from both because that's what
simultaneous equations means and just
support because I was having this
conversation earlier and it's it it's a
nice segue to something else I wanted to
already mention I know I know that both
of these comfy right at the same time it
has to be this one or this one or some
clear answer that no one is coming
because everyone is wrong okay I'm doing
broadly agree with this okay now let's
confirm it because we've talked about
solving by elimination we've talked
about solving by substitution there's
actually a third way that you know to
solve some say square is substitution
elimination you can solve these
graphically now I know why people didn't
go to graphically because you're like
graphene takes time
why would you do that when you can do it
algebraically and it's all quite quick
and I agree with that okay however it's
useful at this point draw me a cell axes
because this would be critical as we
move into the rest of this lesson what
we gonna do is we want to understand
what is this actually asking like when
you get a pair of numbers out of this
whether it's this or this what does that
pair of numbers one of those values
signified okay to solve this graphically
what you need to remember is that these
two equations can each be represented
graphically
they're both straight lines so we call
these maguey we call these linear
equations nothing's been Square
nothing's being divided so you're going
to get straight lines out of this you
can see it's not too difficult to
imagine what these are going to look
like for example this first one here I
mostly to graph this and have an idea of
what it looks like
you would probably put this into MX plus
B slope-intercept form okay if I did
that here it would be y equals what will
be the left hand side minus 2x because
that you subtract a from the side plus 1
minus 2x plus 1 so do you have a picture
in your head of what it looks like you
can see where the y-intercept is gonna
be and the gradient of negative 2 tells
you is sloping down right and quite
steeply so let's just roughly draw we
only need to get a rough idea so if I
call this one
that's equation one in a big shot right
ok let's have a look at the next one
X minus y equals negative 4 again if you
rearrange that just a little bit you
could add Y to both sides and then you
can also add 4 to both sides if you
added Y you'll end up with y equals
something you add 4 and that leaves you
with on the left hand side you can have
an X the Y is gone and you have X plus 4
X plus 4 what does that look like
that looks like something I can fit on
my graph so I'm going to rub out some of
my board y equals x plus 4 has a
y-intercept of 4 so that's why you can
see I'm going to draw this little bit of
fire and it has a great a nerve 1 which
means it's increasing it's going up and
sort of it of general right not as steep
as this ok so therefore if I've got that
is one that would make that 2 + 3 + or -
lets draw love this little further and
then I'm going to draw this just use
your imagination there you go now here's
the lovely thing about this ok without
actually doing a substitution I can
already see I know in the ballpark in
which my solution must lie did you see
that so you can notice all right
x equals negative 1 does that seem
consistent with where I'm finding my
point of intersection it does right over
there on the left-hand side of the y
axis what happens 3 that's already
reasonable yeah now on my diagram it
doesn't perfectly line up that's because
I've got no greater was a bit of a quick
and dirty version but yeah look see it's
the below 4 so I have to be in the right
area and if you want you can do it
algebraically to really satisfy yourself
ok